it's monday november seventeenth and
it's time for gamespot news Chris waters
here to carry the news torch for the day
and illuminate all the dank castles and
dark sewers and drafty forests of gaming
news for you Oh encrypt can't forget
crits news time there's a big patch
hitting for destiny today not big in the
sense that they're like doing one real
big thing but more in the sense that
there's like a crap ton of little stuff
among the more notable updates our new
voice chat options that will facilitate
chat between strike and crucible teams
as well as allow local area chat for
those who opt in New shaders the ability
to pick up twice as many bounties and
some tweaks to the upcoming run of the
multiplayer event iron banner are also
on the list which you can find posted in
its entirety at gamespot.com / news the
wii u version of watch dogs is real
Ubisoft didn't forget about it even
though you might have and it's shipping
internationally this week although
Ubisoft announced that some DLC will not
be coming to the Wii U specifically the
single player add-on titled bad blood
there will be 2 DLC packs available on
the Nintendo eShop namely the augmented
reality mission conspiracy and the
preorder bonus pack access granted at
long last you can finally pretend your
Wii U gamepad is the world hacking
smartphone you've always wanted it to be
huge news in the MMO space this week as
one of the biggest names in video gaming
is delivering an epic massive expansion
that's right folks it's an MMO expansion
for goat simulator titled go MMO
simulator with a level cap of 101 and
five different playable classes one of
which is a microwave with legs this is
obviously the place for MMO fans to be
this week as pretty much nothing else is
going on in the MMO space also it's a
free update and finally some screenshots
have leaked from Telltale's Game of
Thrones Game giving you a look at your
favorite Westerosi in that distinctive
telltale art style the game will
chronicle the story of house Forrester a
canonical yet little seen house in
Martin's books and will start near the
end of season 3 of the TV show telltale
has yet to confirm the authenticity of
these images but they look like the real
deal
you can clearly tell who these
characters are check it out you've got
Tyrion the IMP Cersei the cranky Marge
the marriage lady the frowny battle bros
horse and Anakin and obi-wan sink
totally legit for more real and actual
news be sure to visit gamespot.com /
news and have a great week